hey guys welcome back to your weekly dev
stream recap video and before the starts
though I just want to preface this that
there's going to be two videos today one
right now one after the other the first
one is going to be about the patch notes
and only the patch notes including the
new emotes executions and balance
changes that are coming out next week
and then the next video after this is
going to be dedicated strictly to the
DLC characters and their moveset emotes
executions and their new armor there's a
lot of info today it was about almost a
two-hour livestream as compared to its
normal 1 hour livestream
so that's why I'm kind of separating the
videos here so that we can have kind of
it's just more organized and it was it
was so annoying trying to get all his
piece together anyway boys let's start
it so anyway the first thing on the list
is all season pass owners will have the
characters on May 16th for free and non
season pass owners will have the
characters on May 23rd for 15,000 steal
new territories are being announced
which are the three areas I'm showing up
on-screen which are the statue and then
to the left and the right of the statue
for each faction may be hinting that
we'll actually be able to take a faction
stronghold if we get close enough there
was no new content this week because the
devs wanted us to save our steal for
next season which is very kind of them
there is a new bundle in the game coming
whether that's next week or the week
afterwards which is a content for the
Vikings winning so if you want to buy
this bundle or acquire steal the bundle
comes with pre-existing ornaments
executions emotes everything that the
Vikings have but only for the Vikings
because they did win the season remember
these are pre-existing items these are
nothing new so they're always going to
be in the game already so that's
completely up to you whether you want to
buy this or not now I did mention that
there wasn't going to be any content
this week because they didn't want to
save or steal but next week they're
going to be adding three new outfits per
hero new effects and they were called
the optical illusion spotter and Virgo
for the outfits along with the bat out
effect for executions in emotes which I
will show to you right now
you
you
you
so that was pretty cool though I kind of
I think my personal favorite was the
splatter effect can't wait to put that
on some of my characters when they come
out though
but anyway next up is they showed off
some of the new epic tier armor for some
of the characters which is on screen now
I really do enjoy some of these items
especially warden's in my opinion they
did I did they did show Raiders and
Kent's A's but I liked worden
specifically because it just kind of was
a lot more shinier and stuff like that
but they were only the weapons they
didn't really show off much of the gear
it was just the weapon items and such
next up is matchmaking now takes into
account your reputation level making it
easier to find players of your skill
level which you will have and you will
probably have to select your hero before
matchmaking and the beginning that if
you are a player that plays a lot but is
really garbage then you'll be matched up
players that play a lot but are really
garbage so trying to make it exactly how
you play so if you are really good but
haven't really played too much then
you'll get matched up of players such as
those if you have so if you have a lot
of reputation you're going to be matched
up with characters that also have a lot
of reputation on them is like little
magical numbers you're like total rep
there now in terms of the hero buffs
Raider finally got the buff that we've
been looking for and now changes it so
that every heavy or zone attack can now
be canceled into the stunning tap move
which is the move where he jumps forward
and then slams the butt of his little
axe into your head and stuns ooh his
little stamp in charge where he charges
at you and grabs you now takes less
stamina to use if you hit a wall during
Stampede charge his knee will do 15
damage in top of zero so it's now adding
the damage on top of the stunning effect
that it already has his leg combo
attacks also got an increased damage by
5 and his stamina pool also got
increased by 10 from 120 to 130
Peacekeeper got nerfed again her bleed
damage does a damage over 8 seconds for
all three stabs instead of 15 for 8 or
for 8 seconds exploiting moves such as
unlocking during a certain attack to
prevent the enemy from blocking has been
removed from the game as well it's now
treated like a regular move if you have
no idea what I mean by these don't worry
about it it was a very scummy move it
basically people would do combos while
they were like mid-swing they would
unlock
causing the player not to be able to
block it even though it's a normal light
attack it is now and not in the game
anymore so don't worry about that Kent
says little or his new execution which
was the no-look kill that was just added
recently is now a hundred milliseconds
slower no clue why this needed a patch
but I guess it needed it now the
characters are done we can now move on
with the rest of the patches XP gained
across all game modes whether you win
tie or lose has been increased by
roughly 70 or 100 extra xpeke depending
on whether you win lose or tie and the
game mode you are playing if you play
more dot if you play Dominion and win
you'll get more but if you play duel and
win you won't get as much as the
Dominion game also when there's no gear
equipped in a certain slot you gain
additional stat bonuses so for example
arms and defense increases the stats on
the arms by 0.8%
the body's 0.9 head is 0.6 weapon 1 is
0.8 weapon 2 is 1% and then weapon 3 is
1.2 percent I don't exactly know what
they mean by weapon 1 2 or 3 we'll have
to find out maybe it's a combined thing
like maybe if you have one item equipped
and then you have two unequipped that
would count as weapon 2
I don't know how that exactly would work
they didn't exactly split explain it
that well at least from what I was
hearing but this does make it easier for
new players to compete with other
characters that and other characters
that have high gear scores instead of
getting their ass beat super quickly
the only patch regarding game modes is
that you can be revived once per round
in elimination now instead of constantly
being revived all the time when you die
and just like I said in the last video
there's also a new tier of gear called
epoch which is the orange gear and all
the items you now upgrade cost less
Salvage and steel and you gain more
Salvage when you dismantle items so that
is going to be the end of this little
dev stream recap this wasn't actually as
long as I expected it to be we're about
it's about five minutes maybe five and a
half minutes long it would have been way
way longer but the move sets for all the
new characters was the bulk of the dev
stream this week so I'm going to be
putting that in a video
the next video in a couple hours I just
got to get this one rendered and then
fix the next one and then that should be
it so like I said if you all if all you
wanted to save is the patch notes you
can be you can finish this video
obviously or if you want to go see the
DLC characters as I said in the
beginning you can go to the next video
or if you're a nice person you just want
to watch both then I'll see you in the
next video guys with a peace out I'll
see you all in the next video